[Música]
pasamos a nuestra revista de prensa Como
cada mañana hoy con Marta Moya Marta
Buenos días para usted Buenos días
Ángela tres temas importantes tenemos
hoy vamos a abrir con un artículo de
financial Times que resume Cómo se gestó
el acuerdo de Windsor entre Richie zonac
y uso la van der Legend Y a partir de
unas negociaciones secretas que
iniciaron al comienzo del mandato de
sonac Así es Ángela el financial Times
hace esta especie de recopilación de
cómo se fraguó este acuerdo entre sunak
y bonder Legend no fueron cuatro meses
de diplomacia a escondidas que empezaron
en la Cumbre de la cop 27 en charman
Shake en Egipto y concluyeron este lunes
con bonder Legend tomándose el té con el
Rey Carlos III después de haber firmado
ese acuerdo con el Primer Ministro estos
cuatro meses marcan una disposición del
premiere de alcanzar ese acuerdo ese
acuerdo del protocolo de Irlanda algo
que la Unión Europea consideraba que su
antecesor Boris Johnson no había estado
nunca en esa disposición en Egipto ambos
mandatarios se reunieron primero
hablaron de la guerra en Ucrania de
cambio climático y después empezaron a
abordar este tema de el protocolo nori
Irlandés a esta conversación después se
sumaron según el final Times James
clevery que es el secretario de
relaciones exteriores de Reino Unido y
por la parte de la Unión Europea el
vicepresidente maros sefocovich después
a principios de este año Ya empezaron
una serie de reuniones secretas en
Bruselas en un edificio normalmente
destinados a cosas de oficina en el
edificio philiple Von donde las
conversaciones empezaron a tener otro
cariz y empezaron a desgranarse esos
pormenores para eliminar las fricciones
de las relaciones comerciales entre
Reino Unido e Irlanda del Norte y la
Unión Europea pero las conversaciones no
fueron fáciles de hecho
dice que en dos momentos enero y A
mediados de febrero las conversaciones
estuvieron a punto de romperse dicen
Fuentes conocidas incluso a este medio
que las personas que participaban desde
evento decían que incluso podían sacar
una botella de Whisky para amortiguar el
golpe pero finalmente Pues todo salió
bien Hasta el momento pero estamos
esperando aún esta que la ciudadanía
Pues refrende de alguna manera este
pacto no y que no se vaya a pique Pero
bueno vamos a cambiar de tema y vamos a
hablar de un reportaje que saca hoy el
medio independiente ruso
Moscú Times sobre los periodistas
locales rusos y como ellos tienen que
hacer las investigaciones y el conteo de
Las bajas rusas en el frente de la
guerra ante lo que llaman una poca
transparencia brindada por el kremlin
Así es Y es que Ángel al gobierno ruso
pues no está muy acostumbrado a brindar
datos reales y oficiales de Las bajas de
su ejército en Ucrania no Y antes pues
esta poca transparencia los periodistas
independientes locales en Rusia han
tenido que asumir estas labores de
identificar verificar y contar las bajas
de las tropas rusas no Esta es una una
iniciativa del medio media son en
conjunto con el servicio ruso de la bbc
y en los últimos días incluso han pedido
esfuerzos para redoblar estas
investigaciones y han pedido a
voluntarios que se sumen pues hacer una
base de datos nacional con la que medias
y el servicio ruso de la bbc Ya
contabilizan al menos 15.000 muertos un
dato que en la realidad podría ser al
menos el doble este artículo del mosqui
Times refleja un periodo una cifra de un
periodista de mediasón que dice no es un
trabajo feliz pero alguien tiene que
hacerlo queremos mostrarle al público
que incluso para la Rusia la Rusia
patriótica para la rusa la Rusia Pro
Putin la guerra tiene un costo y ese
costo son los soldados rusos los
periodistas que cubren las muertes de
los soldados rusos en las regiones del
lejano Oriente incluso perciben
obituarios muy similares no que dicen
como algo así se graduó en la secundaria
se alistó al ejército y murió en Ucrania
Esta es una tarea cada vez más difícil
porque antes las administraciones
regionales aportaban este dato y ahora
pues lo hacen las administraciones
locales y a cuentagotas es cada vez un
trabajo de menos transparencia por parte
del gobierno ruso los voluntarios además
trabajan bajo condiciones de anonimato
porque como decimos no O sea hablar del
ejército en Rusia incluso está penado
para los propios periodistas recorren
cementerios hacen fotografías sin que
sean percibidos y después los ciudadanos
rusos pueden ver si sus familiares están
en este registro de víctimas en un Bot
en la aplicación Telegram mire muy
importante además Marta esta tarea para
la memoria no que que nos permitirá
revisar el pasado y sobre todo para las
familias vamos a terminar con un tema
que lleva en los medios internacionales
muchas semanas las inteligencias
artificiales llegaron para y esto estaba
trayendo además la atención de
inversionistas esto lo cuenta un
artículo en día economist sí los las
inteligencias artificiales no como el
chat gpt esto que tú pones una palabra y
ya te explica más o menos tu propia vida
pues ha empezado a traer la curiosidad
de inversores no Y esto es un análisis
de día economist que dice que entre
ellos entre los propios inversores han
nacido una nueva fiebre a raíz de el
desarrollo de las inteligencias
artificiales generativas por ejemplo el
pasado 24 de febrero meta la matriz de
Facebook pues anunció el lanzamiento de
llama su propia Inteligencia artificial
Por otra parte y long musk también dijo
que quiere lanzar una Inteligencia
artificial un poco menos vigilada que el
chat gpt y por otra parte el empresario
británico Ben touchel quiere incorporar
también un catálogo de inteligencias que
mezclen filosofía análisis de documentos
propios y ayuda a estudiantes en sus
trabajos aca démicos estas propuestas
pues han atraído a inversionistas por
ejemplo Microsoft anunció en enero que
va a destinar 10.000 millones de dólares
para chat gpt pero también hay
reticencias Porque es un mercado que
está poco explorado incluso ha habido
denuncias por temas de derecho de
autoría y bueno es un tema que va a
seguir dando juego en las próximas
semanas pero que está ahí en la mira de
los inversionistas Yo le diría que los
próximos meses tenemos mucho para hablar
de Inteligencia artificial gracias a
usted Marta gracias Ángela